no no no don't get greedy okay some  people feel it's just not their place to  get involved the only reason that we  even agreed to have you as a foster kid  is because we need extra money and  others tell us our mom didn't cross the  line as long as she wasn't touching or  hitting him there's nothing really I can  do they're more in control of their own  kids they own way you know and they  don't mean you get involved as long as  you don't see any kind of physical abuse  then you you know that's how they handle  their children that's their children now  Caleb pretends he just can't take it any  longer wipe the tears it's ridiculous  and this man trying to embarrass me I'm  in public you don't do that in public  well we'll let him do the talking  no no I understand I'm just trying to  teach him a lesson imagine how he feels  having heard this so far his entire life